hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander and i'm sweating
we're gonna check out Conan's origin
story from Conan O'Brien a lot of people
come up to me and they say Conan how did
you get to be such a great talk show
host
yes it's happened like twice anyway
there are lots of stories online about
how I got started but I want to tell you
none of them are true
now that we are at comic-con I think
it's time I told you my real origin is
door
does look like him
I'm sorry that's the story of the time I
found that quarter I love that quarter I
remember now let's show my real origin
story did you enjoy the show : I loved
him dr. Thomas and Martha Wayne no were
the O'Brien's
he's looking for Bruce Wayne's oh and
dad there were in that alley Thanks
Rule three where's the third one again I
apologize that's the story of how I got
Bruce Wayne's parents killed I remember
it now this finally is my origin story
standing by to detonate sir you sure
there's nobody out there he'll be around
for 200 miles sir all right then on my
103 - doc what happened there's some
good news and some bad news young man
what's the bad news it's your hair
it's permanently stuck that way I'm a
freak what is the good news you were
stuck in the blast zone of an
experimental hilarity bomb
hilarity bomb that's right you were
exposed to massive doses of humor raised
and chortle beams you are now
approximately 5,000 times funnier than
louis c.k and 80 Schumer combined
my mother-in-law stuck a butter knife in
a light socket she's like she really
lights up a room you can see it for
miles
that day a new man was told I would no
longer go by the name [ __ ] Whitley from
that day forward I would be Conan
O'Brien
wait wait come on that is complete
horseshit you were working on The
Simpsons and then Letterman left and you
just auditioned to take his job yet it's
yeah they're not that if that's right I
was yeah I was on The Simpsons and then
I yeah but the point is you're right
Andy but still either way I became
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please lime
subscribe to family whoa
well we don't have to bring up Alan
right now we know you don't like balance
the like Fallon but not while we're
watching Conan's yeah I'm just
disrespectful
I mean LOV Conan is kinda a joke it's a
true joke but it's a joke yeah I would
do anything to go on Conan show I was in
comic-con and cent and I didn't get a
chance to actually go to see Conan that
really bums me out because gosh that I'm
working I'm gonna be working on a poem
for Conan poem for Conan a poem for
Conan you should do a rap poetry song
about him and it should go viral and
then you should be on your show
then I'll react to my viral video oh
yeah
Conan oh yeah then Conan will react to
my viral video that would be B Oh commit
that's the plan guys of how I'm gonna
get Conan's attention
I'm gonna write a Conan rap song you
guys are gonna share it tweet it to Team
Coco guy do all the work you guys gotta
do all the work for us and then it'll go
viral they'll become a YouTube sensation
I'm pretty much a youtube sensation
200,000 followers that is what you
consider sensational I've been
recognized five times Sally the other
day I got recognized at a subway really
yeah you know this guy said you do um
YouTube right yeah cool
I feel pretty special well uh yeah Conan
if you're watching this I would love to
come on your show and also guest star on
the show oh oh did you hear that [ __ ]
that plug-in ha I said I would love to
come on the show and also guest star on
the show see now he's not gonna have you
on user in it
what do you mean Conan would love to see
my come come Conan that's what I would
say to you in bed come Conan come Conan
sounds like I'm calling a puppy
come Conan yeah if you come code orange
fluffy things yeah not gonna get that
kind of dog guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects right you can check out
salamander scholars channel on the sally
channel and i'm gonna renew the sounds
sally channel and you can check out our
sketch that we just did in between takes
with riot and sally on this channel
follow us on facebook instagram twitter
vine periscope and yo let's do a shout
out cuz we're youtubers and we behave so
wacky to entertain you guys oh look at
our stick however so charming oh my god
people love us because of how we're
willing to be silly in front of the
camera oh my god
okay soos vera shout-out please you guys
are so awesome each and every one of
your reactions are hilarious
hope you get to 1 million subs by doing
this year wow wow well can you make that
happen to me awesome he can if there's a
man's gonna make it happen it's gonna be
Jesus yeah his name is Jesus yeah Jesus
is the one who's gonna help us go PS
love you Ryan no home I don't have a
home PS Ryan I love you I don't have a
home can I move in with you one day I'm
pretty sure you man no homo no homo okay
maybe a little
it's okay Jesus but Jesus we need your
help if we're gonna get to 1 million
subscribers I'm gonna be talking to you
an awful lot these days you didn't need
to answer me back some time verbally now
with no signs and all that yeah and like
oh greed is not good yeah whatever I've
heard of billion times I need your help
to get to 1 million subscribers because
that's where the money is at hmm that's
where the opportunity is at what I think
Tyrone's always like 1 million
subscribers because Tyrone knows you
know is he want that gold youtube he
wants that gold YouTube placard so Jesus
véra me the Lord be with you
namaste